[Musique]
salut à tous et envergure et comme on en
a l'habitude alors ça arrive un peu tard
mais on va vous donner des émissions
thématiques avant la draft c'est à dire
qu'on va regrouper les joueurs par rôle
c'est à dire en gros trois types de
rôles ceux qui ne foutent pas et qui
évolue plus près du cercle ce qui shoote
et puisqu'on le ballon entre les mains
soit plus des rôles offensifs que
défensifs après y aura évidemment des
nuances et tutti quanti à chaque rôle
sont membres de l'équipe on commence
avec les grands les pigs ou lecteur on
verra on va faire des nuances avec alan
ça va très heureux de table pour prendre
les intérieurs surtout quand on connaît
très heureux
c'est ça c'est cei a appris à aimer les
intérieurs
ce que je vous ai demandé de faire donc
on aura les boilers avec manu et les
wings avec hugues with les ailiers
letwin dit comme on dit
déjà déjà je vous ai demandé de définir
un peu les dif le panel qui existait en
nba et qui donc
pouvait être projetés comme un rôle pour
les prospects cette année donc déjà toi
est ce que tu peux me donner le parmi
les grands la valeur la plus haute le
rôle le plus haut le meilleur rôle pour
un grand qui existent en une bière déjà
ça super intéressant parce que je pense
qu'il ya une différence entre saison
régulière est meilleur je pense qu'en
saison régulière le rôle le plus qui
vraiment était le but ce soir après soir
c'est le rôle de protecteur de cercle
sur donc sur drop moque lopez pour
simplifier c'est à dire le grand qui va
vraiment annihiler toute tentative au
cercle st cajetan rappeur de driver
khroubi sera là donc seront là le rôle
de rudy gobert ce genre de rôle un avec
encore un petit à petit changement parce
que c'est vrai que la polyvalence et la
capacité à être sûr du switch peut aider
il ya aussi d'autres types de rôles
c'est à dire que sur le rôle défensif on
a le rôle de second couteau de deuxième
lame qui est à paraître plus en plus
depuis depuis quelques temps
ski et gianni savio kiska robert
williams quand il est en bonne santé à
boston
ça peut être des joueurs plus petits ça
peut être déjà romer un peu plus petit
pays un peu plus petit mais qui sont
très très tonique très con qui monte
très vite très haut qui en bon sens or
plus loin du ballon pour participer et
qui viennent animer leur deuxième ligne
ils ont des fois pas assez puissant
comprend le premier le premier impact
mais ils sont là pour annuler les
actions comme ça offensivement il ya
d'autres types de rôles mais sérieux
défensivement on est plutôt sur soi de
drogue soit du second coup du second
rideau soit du hac vaste et a souhaité
chapeau on a deux types de couvertures
des choses qu'on regarde le plus je
pense ouais et donc le le le joueur le
plus valorisé en saison régulière celle
utilisée brook lopez rudy gobert
maintenant
je ne sais pas comment tu fonctionnes
dante et board dudes naturel nous
expliquer mais en playoffs pour une
équipe qui gagne peut-être que le rom
heure où le celui qui peut switch
sachant que le maître étalon du gars qui
sait pas shooter mais qui est tellement
utile à une équipe c'est dreams and
green
c'est un gars qui peut faire les deux
qui peut switch qui peut romecki peut
encaisser le premier contact il peut un
petit peu tout faire
mais il est pas forcément très grand
donc ça sent la capacité à switch pour
toi les plus importantes quand évaluant
prospects que celle d'être même un
excellent joueur de drop c'est superbe
c'est sûr il ya deux ans je t'aurais dit
oui vraiment des gens qui étaient
incapables de switcher je devrais
vraiment baissé sauf qu'on peut sous
coté sur la saison régulière l influence
que ça peut avoir sur un sur les
intérieurs qu'on sélectionne je suis ans
et fait un intérieur dans la deuxième
partie du premier tour et qui t'apporte
du drop solide sur 81 82 matchs séquence
du temps que les offres peut jouer 15 20
minutes c'est dire vraiment positif
puisque beaucoup de tables des fois sur
rudy gobert ou sur d'autres met illico
baird s'est lavé des meilleurs extérieur
à côté des meilleurs ailiers ça aiderait
ils se retrouvent pas tous temps en
grande difficulté en play-offs message
que le switch parce que c'est rare parce
que c'est
moi je pense m'en être bien petit peu
vrillé rapidement sur evans mobley
puisque dès début d'année commencé à
switcher un peu sur un extérieur et à
bien les tenir c'est sûr que c'est c'est
impressionnant c'est fort mais je pense
que le drop quand même droit il a la
capacité a très bien géré le drop est
extrêmement volley ball nba ouais c'est
une plus une danse alors que finalement
gérer le switch en vrai si on raisonne
très simplement et qu'on même quelqu'un
qui connaisse pas le basket on dit bah
en fait c'est le joueur qui va être le
cap capable de le stopper en un contre
un le maximum de joueurs adverses que ça
vous savez d'un joueur grand kiss &
switch est le meilleur défenseur
possible en rencontrant bon en gros
à la fois puissant et long et mobile
alors déjà est-ce que parmi le
top 5 attendu et ce que t'en considère
est-ce que tu les considère comme des
biggs les banques queiros miss hongrie
après c'est un grand pour racheter un
big les deux autres sont des défauts des
grands froids des déposes tout cas
parce que chet pour un peu très bon
endroit vraiment protéger la note us que
les deux autres ok on va évidemment on a
déjà on vous renvoie sur nos portraits
drafté sur eux on va pas parler d'eux
qui est le premier à venir sur ton board
et quel prototype fit-il ou peut-il cité
c'est john john premier
challenger n
ont fait une présentation on va à chaque
fois donc on vous conseille si vous
pouvez avoir votre notre big board sous
les yeux ou où les fiches des prospère
on les mettra également dans la
description de la vidéo ou du podcast
selon si vous écouter ou regarder
néanmoins on va faire comme une petite
présentation à chaque fois mais sommaire
puisqu'on va parler évidemment de
beaucoup plus de prospects jaden du
renne qui jouait à du côté de memphis
cette année de 11 2 26 d'envergure 113
kg sont les mesures actualisée du nba
comme gbagbo qu'une bête physique quand
on n'a plus vu depuis même et y tenait
un peu au-dessous je crois quand il
rentrait me
johanne je me suis dit ah c'est
simplement la dernière fois que j'avais
un notamment troisième sert à
l'intérieur que je considérais un peu
pas extrêmement poli offensivement mais
avec de vraies capacités défensives la
capacité athlétique c'est un écho au
kangoo et je me suis dit est ce que
j'aime autant turenne koh kong où j'ai
dit oh oui donc j'ai dit je peux pas le
descendre trop bas même si c'est pas un
intérieur que je vois être
extrêmement dominant ou forcément une
cei il a il a des soucis de lecture
encore mais il ya des flashes très
positif sur sur la passe sur la vision
juste comme ça il est très très jeune il
est de novembre 2003 il avait été puis
défensivement même si par moment il est
encore très c'est normal très saute pas
mal où il peut pas lire et comprendre
tout ce qui se passe sur un sur un
terrain de basket on achète encore on
achète un joueur qui jeudi fait plus de
2 10 à plus de 2,25 d'envergure et déjà
plus de 110 kg et c'est pas du gras on
sait non donc je ne compte pas vu les
photos il ya des photos qui tourer carte
de foreman ans exactement donc on achète
au bout du suspense de paris sur le
phénomène athlétique physique de dials
et une durée non dans la deuxième partie
de votre réponse alors maintenant dans
la mobilité déjà défensive tu le mets
dans quel rôle
plus un drop je pense je pense qu'on
puisse en 2008 peut encaisser les
contacts qui peut être sur le premier
rideau il ya beaucoup moins de post up
en 2022 qui avant nba mais c'est
quelqu'un qui peut digérer du post up
c'est bien qui peut aussi faire du 2 du
deuxième rideau ce turc plus simple de
faire le deuxième rideau souvent pour
ces gens là parce que ils sont même
s'ils lisent pas trop ils vont quand
même ou d'en voir que va avoir un lay up
de tenter wa chose comme ça arriverait
ils sont ils sont plus grands plus
costaud plus long il arriva peut
annihiler je pense que sur des
situations de switch ou pas s'attendre à
des choses incroyables il fait 2 10 il
est déjà plus de 110 kg donc il y arrive
moi je trouve un peu un peu lourd
parlement sur ses déplacements latéraux
je pense que ça va être comme celui de
protecteur de dano un jour puissants
cercles
si on attaque un finisseur ni sur quoi
que pose est
comment tu le compares j'ai dit diane
drayton j'ai pas d'idée andré tonnes
pour rien comment tu le compares à
l'arrivée dans la ligue défensivement et
offensivement dans la mobilité fine
bonjour à corps on va voir je préfère
beaucoup plus le jeu offensif dayton qui
était bien plus qu'ils étaient capables
de d'avoir dû mi distance mais j'aurais
aussi mais c'était pas des flashs
c'était du mes distances voilà solide où
il en est sûr une année de sciez c'était
un touché c'était pas un joueur qui
était avec des pourcentages eux aussi
bas dans certains domaines défensivement
je pense que je préfère 10 juin mais
étonne est devenu un as khroub défenseur
et je pense qu'on pensait tous pas
qu'ils pouvaient vraiment devenir ce
jour là mais je pense que je préfère le
corps de le corps et les capacités
athlétiques de duren à son entrée dans
la ligue
du règne donc le les drapeaux jaunes
serait une adresse aux lancers francs et
à mi distance moyenne aux lancers francs
on est à 60 2 % si je ne m'abuse c'est
sa 62 et demi et sur les deux points
long on est à 36 % ce qui est pas s'il
s'est pas tu reçois pas atroce
qui vient ensuite au niveau des
intérieurs et quel rôle ensuite j'ai pas
comme ça à peu près tous les ans c'est
souvent la fin du tiers du tir 4 souvent
c'est ce que le projet temps vraiment et
très les profils esthétique physique que
sur lequel je veux parier pour être
rigoureux heures pour être vraiment là
où j'étais j'ai même beaucoup pour
l'heure il ya deux ans là où l'année
dernière j'étais un peu dans ce genre
toujours la ga ga groupe avec pas mal de
joueurs donc c'est mark williams juke
oui j'ai donc ça diabaté michigan djédjé
lyn williams de arkansas et ismaël
kamagaté du paris basket ball
j'ai walker questeur d'auburn et j'ai
john butler de florida state donc ça
c'est un droit de jeter les 6 lits
auxquels offensivement ferait du riz
brun toi n'ont pas tous mais ici c'est à
dire que mark williams moussa diabaté il
se mettre comme agathe et frais du
rimeront avec certains et certaines
nuances dans les jeux john butler un
profil plus grave parce que lui il
stretch
capable de tirs à trois points walker
kessler et jason williams je sais un peu
moins pour en faire des mais aussi
comment ça peut attirer il s'est un peu
passé mais fait rien de très bien en
termes de spécialisation et walker
kessler c'est un finisseur proche du
poignet qui commence à peler un tir à
trois points mais c'est sur un volume
qui peut pas me garantir qu'ils en
prennent à respecter donc c'est juste g3
où j'essaie vraiment ce que vont faire
les trois autres c'est je suis intrigué
par certaines choses
qu'elle quel volume il faut une question
un peu bâtard mais comment comment tu
comment tu les évaluations très bonne
question kevin williams est quasiment
deux tirs à trois points tentés par
match et
73 % aux lancers francs sur quatre
lancers francs tentés pour match sur
cette année il a fait que deux ans
initié walker kessler c'est pareil c'est
encore moi c'est à dire que c'est un
point pour tenter par match c'est ce que
60 % aux lancers francs donc pour les
deux je suis pas convaincu encore qui
seront respectés qui peuvent être
installés comme un nouveau pan dans un
shooter qui seront pas non plus défendu
comme des noms shooter mais parce que
ces deux sophomore donc c'est des
joueurs qui en plus ce n'était pas très
mises en avant à leur première année
donc l'échantillon il est dit par
incroyable je ne veux te leur déjà pour
vous pu shooter à trois points john
butler n'a que shooter à 3 exactement
demandé hier pour moi et moi j'avais moi
je pense que je l'aurais mis dans les
dents les ailiers des rwandais dans mes
groupes face qui défendra ni d intérieur
ni l'attaquera sur des intérieurs alors
même si c'est deux médians il peut il
peut avoir le groupe de second rideau je
pense à terme même s'il n'est pas
extrêmement verticale comme mais je vois
ce que tu veux dire on commence par le
premier mark williams de 95 le stenting
reach donc debout les bras levés il est
presque à l'anneau il joue à duke cette
année en deuxième deuxième année à duke
il a des chiffres évidemment très très
impressionnant
d'ailleurs certains borde le voit très
haut le voit presque l'autre et j'ai
l'impression j'ai l'impression qu'on en
a un peu moins parler ceci dit c'est ces
derniers temps de mark williams mais
donne donne moi ce ses qualités
défensives déjà gelé du à charlotte dans
des morgues draft 13h15 donc oui oui bah
charlotte qui a toujours ses problèmes
récurrents et ses intérêts marc wilhem
c'est peut-être dias là je pense qu'on a
pu passer à côté si on se concentrait
pas sur lui sur les matchs doute parce
qu'il est tellement prospects dans cette
équipe que c'est peut-être pas su
comment garder le plus mais passé le
finisseur ultime à la noce et 70 % aux
tirs en 62 matchs entiers
62% c'est vraiment incroyable c'est une
belle progression dans ces francs cette
année il passait de 53% à 72 % et gagner
devant point donc pour ces jours-là
focale qui puisse mettre des lancers
francs parce que sinon
ça se voit ces problématiques en plus
bien sûr c'est un joueur que j'avais
pris deux paniers à trois points aux
initiés donc c'est un finisseur de
l'homme c'est un joueur très grand qui
est sûre du rebond offensif c'est un
joueur qui prenait 13 % de rebond
offensif pour inquiéter sur tes hanches
jim courant non plus un don qui y est
vraiment celui là tu sais pas vraiment
un passeur c'est plus vraiment un
finisseur finisseur offensivement
est ce qu'il ya un profil
nba auquel il est comparable
[Musique]
mitchell robinson
ouais ce genre de jour là un peu plus
loin daniel rigaud kfor d'un peu plus
grand que t'être ce genre de fille là je
pense oui des joueurs qui vont pas chou
théâtre à trois points mais qui vont
être intéressants avec leur adresse aux
lancers alors ghafour je sais plus
combien il a cette année mis les paris
di cule choix je crois que c'était pas
ridicule on adore et
mark williams
plusieurs
ce cas où tu dis ce qu'il a à
l'entraînement dès qu'elle bouge de
toucher à mes distances bien plus
intrigante ce qui peut montrer en match
est d'ailleurs en match il y a le volume
est très faible mais 20 sur 46 sur les
longs de points donc on est on est sur
plus de plus de 40% est effectivement 73
pour son lancer parmi le groupe que tu
as cité je pense que c'est lui qui a le
plus gros pourcentage peut-être avec jay
jay lyn williams
quant au
style et à 60,62
genuine jilin williams arc en deçà donc
le même âge que mark williams oui moi
c'est
la même année de la même classe en tout
cas
alors lui est plus petit est ce que tu
donc mark williams on a plus peut-être
l'envisager sur du drop même si même si
ça peut ça peut switcher ce qui peut
switcher mais
je parierais pas sur des possessions
positive en switch les unes après les
autres peut-être parce qu'il est
tellement long en fait par moments il ya
peut-être pouvoir annuler le lan est
native au cercle par sa longueur tu a
rappelé sur la steg sur la même sur
l'envergure à l'est à plus de 32 de
mémoire c'est très grosse envergure ça
phénomène athlétique physique mais jay
leno williams est plus dans le switch
alors que c'est peut-être un athlète
moins tonique que l'otsc intéressant oui
mais plus horizontale peut-être
concrètement ''j'ai lyn williams 2 10-2
16 d'envergure 107 kg mesure aux
combines 73 % aux lancers francs pour
les mesures importantes effectivement
quasiment 2 3 points tentés par match
mais seulement 24 ans en
mai mais il ya évidemment des stats
intéressantes
notamment au niveau de la protection de
certains robots mark williams ont été à
11% de compte évidemment mais lui l'a 4
% + 2 % de style et puis offensivement
45 un free trail de 45 ça veut dire
qu'ils bombardent portion de passion
provoque des fautes 15 % de passes toit
ce qui t'intéresse sais quoi dans son
profil déjà c'est marrant mais c'est le
meilleur intérêt que j'ai vu pour
croquer les passages en force il est
donc le cuit je trouvais excédents des
fonctions il nie super league - billy
testing nous exhalons mobilité fine
dining vision à compréhension il est
coachée par eric musulmane qui est un
des meilleurs coaches comptent y est
gentil fait du super travail arkansas en
fait je trouve qu'il a une superbe bruni
fait de très bonnes lectures malgré son
jeu elle m'avait déjà on peut intriguer
l'an dernier mais je jouais pas beaucoup
il jouait très peu il joue elle joué 15
minutes par match cette année il a été
vraiment place en tant que titulaire a
joué 32 minutes par match donc pour
l'intérieur de 20 ans c'est à dire que
tu peux en panne et un an de foot tu
peux rester sur le terrain c'est quand
même quelque chose à noter très bon dans
la lecture je trouvais puis une palette
offensive qui je trouve est et très
intrigante par ba le développement d'un
tir qui peut quand même ce qui doit
quand même se mettant en place c'est à
dire que j'ai déjà écrit scouting des
portes en cours d'année mais est allé à
l'époque il était à 69 % ses frontières
sur la fin d'année il a progressé comme
on monte elle était aussi à cette époque
là à 35% sur des lions de points ce qui
était bien donc je pense que on achète
un profil assez intriguant de
l'intérieur qui peut être un peu
polyvalent qui peut faire ils ne tuent
pas trop spécifique ne s'est pas un trou
noir il fait différer un incroyable mais
je pense qu'il peut être utile dans une
rotation
et défensivement alors c'est pas un
c'est pas un switch à fond face disons
que c'est pas john butler dont on a
parlé après qui peut switcher sur deux
qui peut même défendre sur des petits
noms le projet est peut-être sur des
ailiers park web potentiellement oui ben
ali il n'est pas trop grand pour
défendre les ailiers nous voici des mois
une chanson trop grand ordre là où je
l'aimé beaucoup c'est l'impact du rebond
qui l'a quasiment 30% de rebond défensif
parfait oui cet effet c'est vraiment le
grand avec quatre petits au tour donc il
devait vraiment sécurisé ce rebond mais
c'est moins fort rebondeur et dans les
meilleurs joueurs au rebot sur ces deux
années en tant que pourcentage donc
c'est pas un athlète incroyable c
je trouve assez cérébrale qui peuvent
être vraiment un des meilleurs backup en
nba je pense sur ok là encore est ce que
tu as une comparaison évidente elle tout
le monde dans heroes al horford mais non
faut arrêter alors forte c'est le staff
free c'est un retard
cgc gc va
pour moi ça peut être un plus grand
grand trou d'air de son fait mais faut
qu'il tire beaucoup plus un trois points
parce que en tout cas mais en fait ce
qui fait qu'il est jouable et des fois
il est très jouable dans les playoffs
par moments ses tirs à trois-points
s'adresse mais c'est ce genre de weeds
et des liens peu plus de ce qu'on
appelait un ailier fort il ya ya ya
quand on a commencé à trouver moi je
pense à être regardé le basket qui
puisse aujourd'hui un 4/5
qui ne doit pas que tuer ton spécifique
qui permettra pas qui tu danses paix si
moi je pense qu'il peut avoir peut-être
un peu de alors c'est un meilleur
athlète mais il ya un peu de killian
kiely relu ce trou sur certains aspects
qui inquiète un meilleur tireur sûrement
plus bondissant mais dans l'appréhension
collective sur demi terrain
n'apparaissent que rencontrent aucun feu
de sarments que par comparaison mais je
pense que c'est un joueur qui peut se
faire sa place dans une rotation
donc après marc jilin williams il reste
1 williams non il est plus il est plus
bas très violent vous savez un des plus
beaux traits les plus forts dans ce
groupe-là
john butler donc on l'a déjà un peu
d'écrits un grand mais qui joue plutôt
sur les extérieurs alors lui pour le
coup tu l'imaginés en sorte de romer nd
fruits c'est vraiment un rôle rôle à
inventer avec ce qu'il faut vraiment
complètement rôle totalement inventés
oui parce qu'en fait don qui fait 2 15
mai ils doivent faire moins de 85 kg je
pense moi je vais limiter moins de 80
parce que c'était assez ahurissant ce
qu'on a vu au combat il en terme de deux
poids et jean mais extrêmement fine 79
qui voit des roches très haute parce que
c'est un joueur qui
il ya 39 % à 3 points mais par contre
qu'ils étaient à 44% ans et feront donc
est-ce qu'ils maîtrisent réellement son
tir bas il a 19 ans donc c'est un pari
car pour apprendre pour moi en début de
second tour ou fin de premier tour cela
plusieurs piques 1 mais tu veux toi 43%
à 3 points à 2 points à deux points
c'est ce que je reproche aux gabarits
smith et jugera d'intérieur qui vit trop
loin du cercle facilement parce qu'ils
sont trop dans le jump shot parce qu'ils
peuvent pas faire grand-chose d'autre
part moment alors oui c'est encore bien
pire que jabber xmpp
car c'est un joueur qui prenait pas plus
de la moitié de ces tirs à trois points
qui joue avec même pas moins 20 minutes
par l'agent florida state on sait que
les rotations c'est c'est parfois un peu
bizarre mais ouais c'est folklo sa joie
beaucoup ont fait sortir du banc les
meilleurs joueurs vont cesser léonard
d'amis solo de la méthode mais voilà
deuxième rideau mais détroit prenant le
corner on n'a même pas trop vif sur
pick'n pay qu'on a vraiment voulu
prendre les trois points dans le corner
donc c'est un rôle à inventer c'est un
joueur qui doit manger un an de j-league
minimum mais c'est il ya quand même une
rareté du tir à trois points à sa taille
et de la mobilité défensive on a vus
avaler d'aidé très bon meneur adverse va
prendre comme varane c'est williams le
faisait avant lui patrick williams de
scotty barnes être le porteur de ballon
pendant tout terrain mais au moins sûr
d'une demi terrain donc très intéressant
à voir je ne sais pas si ça sera la même
chose la nba mais il a montré quand même
que il peut rester avec ce genre de
joueurs
john butler donc un favori de hugh
jackman videmment
parlons français à la noix on va faire
un un live ou une émission spéciale
français avant la draft ces promus mais
pour cette émission enfin ce thématique
biggs on a deux donc dans ce groupe que
tu as cité
ismaël kamagaté du paris basket ball et
moussa diabaté de michigan est-ce que
quelle est la différence entre les deux
profile déjà
je pense que on sait plus aujourd'hui ce
qui s'est mal kamagaté il ya un an de
plus déjà donc il est installé aux
professionnels depuis plus longtemps on
l'a vu dans un contexte assez simple
pour son développement pro b puis
betclic élite d'ailleurs joué ensemble
les deux à l'euro u18 en 2019 calgary a
été le back up donc ça de moussa diabaté
ou diabaté a été incroyable surtout de
tournoi c'est d'ailleurs sous ce tournoi
là où juwan howard je pense qu'à
recruter il était en grèce pour le voir
et c'était là dessus l'air avant de
marquer dans les manquements diabaté
c'est plus un joueur qui était pas dans
un excellent contexte à michigan à une
équipe qui a été assez décevante qui
avait perdu beaucoup de bons joueurs à
la draft avant qu'elle ait recruté
énormément au 6 mai kamagaté il y avait
été jouée avec dickinson d'un cinq ans
qu'a commencé à tirer sur l'année mais
qui est-elle où l'option une directive
sur un jeu en point à l'ancienne
les porteurs de balle était moins bon
que l'année d'avant tous qu'ils
n'étaient pas toujours bien sérieux
parce que c'est un intérieur finisseur
au panier très tonique donc sur second
sur second sur second dessous qui pulse
gymnase de l'homme le tir s'est
totalement à travailler il ya des
flashes mais c'est à travailler en
termes de volumes ou en termes de
réussite 62% assez froid on l'a dit et
puis défensivement par contre c'est un
des joueurs qui pour moi est la
dépossession switch de plus intéressante
delà de la cuvée sur les intérêts
longtemps oui j'ai eu était en train de
dire j'ai fini avec habileté en disant
qu'il avait des meilleurs processus
parmi les positions des plus
intéressantes en switch mais était
capable vraiment de anil et des
intérieurs dld externe plutôt
virevoltant balle en main parce qu'il
est long il est aux grands il est pas
épais mais il est extrêmement flexible
un profil athlétique après on her polir
est d'ailleurs une des manières de
remarquer ça c'est quand michigan jouer
contre des adversaires on va dire des
coachs intelligents ils étaient pas il
était pas souvent visée parce que des
équipes qui vont rechercher l'intérieur
surtout avec des gros meneurs je pense
au match du tournoi entre face à
tennessee
tennessee n'a pas visées moussa diabaté
sur les switch on est allé chercher un
hunter dickinson on allait presque même
chercher au également
comment il s'appelle john cela brandon
brandon jones généraux jones le le
le le gars qui sortait du banc alors
certes nous ça n'a pas pas eu énormément
de temps de jeu ça dépendra des matches
mais mais quand il était sur le terrain
n'avait on avait une équipe adverse qui
cherchait plus à l'éviter qu'autre chose
ne doit pour toi c'est plus simple
défenseur de switch aujourd'hui ou un
défenseur de couverture second rideau ce
pas exactement une bonne chose pas
évoqué je pense que c'est plus un
défenseur de switch parce qu'il fait sa
rareté dans
dans la cuve et à ce moment là dans la
voir parce que c'est vraiment un rôle
rares et les capacités qui l'a de
mobilité latéral des vitesses de pied de
rotation des hanches de l'ong de
capacités quand même à anne il est un
peu comme un porc constrictor
les pénétrations m'ont vraiment
impressionné c'est un genre qui manquent
de d'appréhension collective c'est un
genre qui manque ce que voilà il a donc
il a fait quatre cinq ans qu'il est aux
états unis donc tu connais un petit peu
les types de jeu mais l'expérience et
les cours intérieures ça se fait sur la
longue durée par des pétitions ou que je
pense que là aussi à yanji parce qu'ils
étaient à mj avant il a aussi bien joué
petit rémy robinson heures qui était pas
tout temps le seul intérieur il avoue
c'est que des joueurs qui vend un essai
l'an prochain qui sont très trop
prospects oui c'était plus que google
vraiment le le défenseur avec cette
mentalité là deux défenseurs qui veut
vraiment stopper l'attaquant adverse
donc il ya beaucoup de choses à faire
mais il ya des capacités athlétiques et
je pense à mein ces attaques sont très
intéressants chez lui est ce qu'on peut
donner un plafond
jean robert williams en moins bons à la
passe
oui on peut lui souhaiter robert
williams et salades et gros flash à la
passe on va se met ses lancers
maintenant les graphismes étaient pas à
texas et m mais s'est lancé à plus de
70% je crois te concentres sur ça mais
vous bien sûr la menace de loeb au
gonflant cif et puis défensivement
playmaker
quelqu'un qui peut vraiment faire des
choses qui sont pas faisable par tout le
monde sait ce qu'on peut lui souhaiter
vraiment de mieux je pense qu'il jouera
plusieurs contrats une vieille
is my peut-être plus dans le drop fils
mail calais - kamagaté par non c'est
plus pour toi c'est un joueur deux drops
en nba où est ce qu'il ya une des flashs
des amants dont il ya un monde où il est
pas il n'est pas du tout ridicule sur
switch on l'a vu en batik l'élite cette
année il ya un monde où s'est posée de
metric et du ketchup anaya beaucoup de
petits manner rouge on cherche beaucoup
les switch on cherche beaucoup à isoler
les petits baigneurs contre les grands
c'est pas pour ça que ma deuxième c'est
amusant bête cycliques parce que c'est
aussi parce que ces gens là où on peut
faire ça et franchement kamagaté basse
et bien sûr il ya il ya eu il ya une
volonté de le mettre en avant par les
médias parce que c'est un jeune joueur
français qui vise la draft mais ces
titres honorifiques il s'est posé sur
ses marchés match après match on a vu un
joueur était extrêmement intéressant
défensivement surtout du drop qui lit
bien les choses qui peuvent en protéger
la no et en plus de ça quelques petits
flash / / / switch qui me font dire que
ce sera ce sera il se fera pas par où il
comptait mur porteur de balle et une
vieille va se permettre
m à la bande mais c'est le cas de tout
le monde donc je pense que j'ai je dis
pas oui mais je dis pas non je viens de
voir la summer league m'intéressera
beaucoup par exemple sur la sueur ça
est-ce que offensivement il a
suffisamment en magasin pour qu'on lui
donne un peu plus de responsabilités qu
être simplement un finisseur rebondeur
offensif
on l'a vu les choses on a vu des choses
cette année on a vu un joueur qui
était capable de faire quelques bons
bonne lecture à la passe on a vu un
joueur qui n'apprenait pas de tir à
trois points et qui me disent qu'ils
finissaient plutôt bien au cercle et
saint jean à 64 % aux tirs c'est quand
même solide au cercle mais je pense que
non n'a pas n'a pas vu des choses assez
répété on avait des flashs on avait des
flashs des mains de dribbles de faim
feinte de fariboles end of ce que fait
pas mal des meilleurs parents pour aller
finir au cercle ou pour ensuite faire
une passe vers l'est vers le coin on a
vu par mois un petit peu de post up mais
c'est plutôt menace de loeb est un genre
qui avait une très bonne entente avec un
joueur comme kyle altman au paris basket
ball et je pense qu'il bénéficiera aussi
des pollens leur n'diaye dire que dans
un contexte beaucoup le mettre dans les
fentes premier tour dans les équipes
comme comme dallas des équipes comme
mais dallas sais pas s'ils voient leur
premier tour au bâton puis s'est montrée
décrit médias laissent ils viennent de
le très malade et donc peut-être qu'un
milwaukee dans des équipes peut-être
comme miami des choses comme ça je pense
que avec un goût des bons porteurs de
ballon pourra vraiment le mettre en
avant un très bon finisseur et c'est pas
grave de ne pas être plus qu'un
finisseur c'est c'est faut dire très
bien le faire très bien sûr spécialisé
là dedans peut-être que les
lancers francs il plafonne après ça fait
trop de trois ans qui doit aux abords de
65 70 % c'est peut-être pour ça on peut
attendre mieux puisque là pour l'avoir
vu ajouté aux échauffements l'image du
paris basket i am et distance il est
plutôt plutôt intéressant mais ça
répète pour un match pour l'instant donc
à voir
qui nous manque dans la liste en
question
walker keszler le coéquipier jabbari
smit à auburn un peu dans le
dans les moules que tu viens de décrire
enfin le même moule que mark williams
si ça marche walker kessler c'est un bon
que lopez version
tiendrait
parce que c'est un joueur qui
protège la no sur drop 19% 2 contre
cette année c'est une stat assez inégal
in stat folle quand il était là on peut
pas aller au cercle pas possible de
culture du drop parce que c'est si tu
avances et un niveau très grand et très
lourd donc de m 16 plus de 115 kg ou
bonne envergure aussi n'est pas une
envie incroyable juste quelqu'un de
grand de grand et de d'épais donc
quelqu'un qui est sûr qu'il est
difficile de finir quand il au panier
même s'il va pas contre et si on peut
être en bonne position
beach à l'est où ils comptent s de tous
pourquoi je dis donc lopez parce que
c'est un joueur qui a commencé à
développer un tir à propres alors sur un
trois points qui n'est pas encore
positif à dire une tentative est ni par
match cette année 20 % de réussite aux
lancers francs qui plafonne toujours su
qu'il 60% donc rien n'est pour ça que
c'est pour ça qu'on fait si shoot à
trois points je lé top 15 en prime top
20 avec une main il est rare mais je
pense qu'on va le faire shooter à trois
points en un peu en nba sens très bien
mais n'est ce pas
sinon je préfère des en fait je peux
perdre rareté des cinq routes qu'on a
mis en avant en fait parce qu'ils sont
plus polyvalents donc même plus de
choses en attaque si walker qu'elle se
retire on aura ce genre qui finit en
panier que je pense 60 70 % à 2 points
avec des porteurs de balle pas toujours
incroyable à à auburn
mais voilà le tir fait que si on a ce ce
stress 5 5 très puissant quittiez qui en
plus peut tirer pas forcément avec la
rythmique du volume volume est assez
important
c'est un profil rare ça que je peux me
tenté en début de deuxième mais je suis
moins fan que ce que je pensais quand
j'étais très fan en janvier février j'ai
revu un peu là j'y crois en commun parce
que at éthiquement c'est pas seulement
un problème et le tiercé j'achète pas
trop de tirs puis c'est pas un profil
qui s'adapte partout non plus quoi
complètement chrysler il faut il faut
avoir enfin dans ce que tu as cité je
dirais le potentiellement celui qui peut
aller à ceux qui prévalaient un peu
partout c'est jean william c'est moussa
est des plus simples appelons la plug
and play oui parce qu'ils n'ont pas
besoin du ballon font des choses très
bien comme polyvalent
le système défensif n'est pas autour
d'eux en plus le système défensif sur le
retour de wally la cantinière parce que
c'est plus d'europe s'il l'a pas faire
autre chose donc ça limite aussi la
polyvalence c'est donc lopez est mal ces
dernières sont très bons dans ce rôle là
mais c'est un acte titulaire et jouer 30
minutes va faire chrysler c'est à dire
que ce sera un joueur de banc au début
qui je discutais tu dois adapter toutes
ont un système défensif de table
deuxième unité c'est assez compliqué
mais ça peut valoir ce bout
alors maintenant on termine donc on
descend d'un cran si l'on y compris dans
sa hiérarchie
donc on va on va plus procéder par rôle
et ce qui reste des drops plus sinister
donc à la caisse leur à la marque
williams oui christian cau locaux
ah oui que j'aime vivre que j'ai en
réalité que j'aime bien je peux l'avoir
dans le groupe un peu mais il est un peu
plus en fait il a 22 ans c'est plus un
produit fini toujours d'arizona mais il
aimait relancé par contre lui il est
laid il était cette année à 73% lancers
francs ce qui est vraiment bien c'est
vraiment un profil de finisseur comme
les autres à 10% de compte dans ce 3
watts y ait un jour ce qui je me
rappelle quand il était franchement
était difficilement jouable il faut pas
trop jouer il se méfie de cibler très
jeune il vient du cameroun
mais voilà quasiment 2,30 d'envergure il
fait plus de 100 kg lui donc il est peut
tenir je pense s'appelle typiquement un
backup l'intérieur finisseur parce que
ce jour là vaut le coup au second tour
khalifa jupp au site et de cuisine
ben khalifa diop donc qui jouait ou
cette année à gran canaria en liga ligue
1 il y avait même un rôle important
parce qu'il a été titulaire il joué
juhan califano en en eurocup et en
championnat c'est à dire c'était c'était
25 minutes non c'était 7 17 minutes par
17 minutes par match en première
division espagnole ce qui est quand même
notable bah oui oui comme un genre
devraient tous les jours ouais
ça faisait plus on peut comparer le
jeu pas si on peut comparer mes 17
minutes en liga c'est un peu moins bien
que les minutes de kamagaté en betclic
élite mais c'est sur le même genre de
d'expérience et s'avancer sur un joueur
qui
il voit 17 minutes pour un des meilleurs
clubs de la d'humeur championnat
domestique ont en europe
et qui joue en plus l'ombre solide après
on a vu
je te mets l'objection maintenant
haussmann garuba alors il ya des preuves
à 100 t on la page qui n'a pas joué
c'était vraiment une ville complètement
tout ce qu'on vendait sur la capacité à
être prêts le garrot pas parce que on
est gay parce que rôles en ligue 1 c'est
pas transmis ce que c'est là est-ce que
c'est sa faute est ce que c'est les
roquettes ce qu'ils ont pas voulu trop
le faire jouer on aura les réponses
prochainement mais c'est en fait s'il
n'y a pas de vérité absolue il n'y a pas
de n'être que des kits des différentes
vérité pour les prospects mais on peut
dire que le job
on va gagner de l'expérience et a eu un
rôle dans une arène d'importance même
alors qu'il reste t-il en rimes runner
efficace menace de loeb est ce qu'il en
reste oui dans mon rêve pas il ya les
revenus qu'ils avaient permis d'entre
eux que je savais c'est yannick enso ça
c'est un peu une ennemie parce que
qu'ils restent candidats du coup oui je
crois qu'ils voient marieville et 10
juin malaga qui était du top 10 avant
l'année parce que des beaucoup de je
pense que j'en avais pas vu on n'est pas
les intel c'est un jour très très très
très brut le congolais mais c'est un
profil athlétique
assez incroyable quand même pour sa
taille le rapport pourra taille
en sus ration comment ils bougent dans
l'espace dont il ya une menace de lock
verticale donc moi je pense qu'il va se
faire a draftés ses tâches et donc pense
que c'est ou alors amené directement et
faire beaucoup beaucoup de digues mais
nécessairement rim renard qui se repaît
de
gauche est d'ailleurs
république du congo et c'est cela et
deux jeux léa de 0,8 il est un peu plus
grand que ça je crois doit être un peu
plus grand mais oui effectivement grande
couverture de terrain faire des contre
impressionnant
2e en deuxième rideau plus pour y voir
complètement voire trop fois encore pour
le premier rideau voilà surtout dans les
gars hasebe c'était très compliqué au
début d'année ouais et paul ii
d'intérieur costaud est ce qu'il reste
des idées des potentiels switcher à la
halle à moussa diabaté ben moi j'ai en
posant son sweat-shirt j'ai
mon chouchou chase lawson qui oui à
profit la c1 et jonte un peu et jimmy
choo toile il shoote donc il peut être
il peut être un poste carte
capable de tenir sur un an un peu des
ailiers mais qui a aussi un peu puissant
pour tenir les 4,5 du genre de fuhrmann
donc je l'aï dit c'est un profit un peu
hybride va avoir peut-être un rôle un
petit rôle en sortie de banc capable de
prendre des intérieurs ne pas être
horribles sur les élites parce qu'il
fait il fait un peu plus de 2 mètres
n'est pas plus sinon j'ai une immense
oasis tomber non mais j'ai subi c'est
marrant tu parles de ce profil là parce
qu'il ya il existe un genre de joueur en
nba qui vous qui va faire du riz brun
offensivement et puis défensivement
défendent plutôt sur des extérieurs on a
on à
gary payton de deuxième le deuxième en
finale qui est en ce moment avec golden
state mais on a aussi bruce bras on a à
brooklyn alors c'est souvent dans des
équipes
de playoffs où ils vont jouer comme sa
fin c'est souvent dans les grosses
équipes mais gionta tout pas beau qu'on
peut dans souvenirs terry jones n est
plus un peu ce rôle en mourant d'eric
jones effectivement un peu ce rôle est
ce qu'il y en a dans cette draft a cité
ce lawson qui est peut-être moins aérien
que tout ce que je viens de citer pour
être une menace de loeb mais voilà
est-ce que est ce que tu vois ou pas des
joueurs de cette draft avoir ce profil
tu me demandais un peu avant avant qu'on
enregistre moi je suis je peux voir
danser c'est joe cheminote le jamaïcain
de memphis
le jamaïcain memphis qui est telle
qu'elle fut qu'une saison à memphis donc
com com du renne qui va la draft qui est
un vrai profil à l'éthique qui pose de
quelques jours dans le game on finisse
heures sera très intéressant sur
flotteurs un peu les push up ce qu'il
faut faire ce qu'il faut savoir mettre
qantas euro la bourse brenntag quand ils
sont solides là dessus mais qui n'a pas
dire extérieur encore donc
si je peux en voir ça serait plutôt aux
jo cheminote je pense qu'il ya eu peut
être vraiment intéressant et polyvalent
en défense très très bon 10 en attaque
aussi fois une bondissant sur la fenêtre
brandissant faut avoir des petits une
petite du petit touché proche du
périmètre donc c'est assez précis comme
comme rôle mais je pense que mes notes
peut être ce jour là ouais c'est pas
c'est pas évident à trouver ce genre de
rôle en nba mais donc josh minutes
qu'est-ce qui tressent des délits
restent des joueurs que tu m'avais tu
voulais envoyer auparavant
peut-être des intérieurs un peu plus
alors on en a et rien peut-être qu'il
reste un européen il me semble matkovic
il est karl markovics
moment là il a eu une cote d'un coup il
est venu au combat ils sont sans
vraiment de côté il a il a assez
impressionné pendant ces workout faut
dire bravo à nico qui avait écrit qui
nous en parle depuis quelques mois donc
il titulaire à mes gars à mes gars avec
nicolas iodice voilà qui tournait à 11
points par match et 6 rebonds chélin
tassin le croate qu'un jeu avec les pas
de la croatie et dans le la fenêtre fiba
dernièrement je serai en février ou en
mars il a dit les bosniens et croate
mais il a pris la nationalité sportive
croître il a 21 ans et au combat et on
l'a vu à son creux des maîtres que des
dingues de partout
détruire les arceaux et puis à ce
fantasme du tir parce qu'ils n'étaient
plutôt adroit sur les 1000 distance mais
que plus fort intéressant par flash ce
week-end pop à mi distance c'est un
joueur qui chute à 60 et 71% lancers
francs cette année
donc fort rebondeur offensif bon
finisseur au cercle et le tir qui
peut-être peuvent venir donc moi il a
été rédigé a shooté à plus de 70 % aux
lancers francs oui si tu est correct
défensivement et qui était une menace de
lock tu peux jouer ça fait deux ans
qu'ils jouent qui joue en première
division 1 et 4 atik qu'il est à 71 %
dans ses fonds de moyenne sur les deux
zones donc voilà c'est c'est plutôt
c'est plutôt solide c'est pas
extraordinaire et non et c'est
il ya quelque chose d'un d'un backup
peut-être quelque part par exemple
d'aller simonovic a été drafté je
préfère carlo matkovic tu préfères
matkovic appelé truth est aussi présent
c'est peut-être plus simple et intégrée
met donc à voir si les deux derniers un
terreau de mes gars qui ont été drafté
ce que m e même sur la troisième voilà
le genre de joueurs alors j'ai beaucoup
de ces c'est pas du tout l'insulté il
n'est pas du tout à ce niveau là encore
mais à la codi zeller quoi
bon un petit peu et c'est vrai zeller ne
vaut pas un top 5 français un très
solide de backup nba sur les deux jours
de rotation
et donc après il tresse des intérieurs
un peu plus à l'ancienne où ils tresques
encore dur film j'ai alors j'ai un
projet - mark bingham juniors c'est un
vrai projet de michigan des vieux déjà
pour un projet il a n'a pas encore 22
ans c'est un jeune senior à sergines
seigneur ok c'est un jeune seigneur dont
80 michigan state il a jamais joué plus
de 18 minutes et cette année joué 18
minutes mais avant c'était un backup sur
pendant trois années rial et xavier
thiemann y avait d'autres jambes donc il
jouait pas mais ce qu'ils prenaient
beaucoup de fautes il fait beaucoup de
burqa ou en ce moment j'ai vu qu'il
avocat pour toronto et la victoire pour
boston aussi donc 2 this de 26
d'envergure
extrêmement il est vraiment très long
et cette année 41 % à 3 points sur plus
d'une tentative pour match 70% lancers
francs dans ces quatre ans initié
il ya un monde où
ça peut marcher ça se termine c'est un
meilleur joueur nba comme une signe
armando si oui fini en europe dans deux
ans mais
je sais pas peut-être un tout et même il
n'y a pas tant d intérieur il ya
beaucoup il ya souvent ce fantasme de
l'intérieur qui shoote - l'iran est en
train de réfléchir en nba qui qui est le
droit naze reid prend des chemins vrai
vrai complètement
la comprennent mais des spécialistes
comme ça il y en a pas énormément
pas beaucoup
donc marcus bingham et après il nous
reste le l'énigme on a pas mal écrit sur
lui
toi tu l'avais cité sans moi je les cite
et pour sûr dans un de mes articles sur
les possibles pépite statistiques très
violent williams donc le meilleur
passeur de ce qu'on a cité depuis le
début on peut le dire voilà que ce soit
statistiquement ou visuellement oui bien
sûr oui complètement genre qui offre un
peu bizarre moi
dans l'équipe championne du 19 avec ken
halliburton diane greene johnsons
barranais mobley cette équipe incroyable
et justes et le back up qui vaut mais
encore été ré était encore beaucoup trop
grave il n'était pas très grand parent
verticale et quelques flashs la face
mais je suis clean ans par un post
publié cette année il a été sonné
sortait du banc parce que purdue donc
fait arte aguidi le canadien lui est
très bien de williams je pense que matte
painter et en est il responsable aussi
c'est un excellent fevad d'attac qui est
facilement évaluables pour la nba mais
il fait de la bonne attaque si tu veux
gagner des matches quand il est parce
que le bol on avait un genre qui est à
34 % de passes décisives cette année
c'est la norme c'est un énorme énorme
[Musique]
spécialiste du post up de faire des
phrases poster des renversements des
kick out excellent dans l'est aussi dans
le jeu à deux c'est à dire s'interroge
humaine va passer il arrive à faire des
pas simples à l'ail au kitsch vert à la
bill walton mais voilà ces
profils extrêmement je sais pas si ça
marche la nba parce qu'il ne tient même
pas trop il ya commencé un petit peu
mais ça n'aura qu'à 52 % aux lancers
francs carrière initiée sur 130 matches
60 quasiment cette année mais
47% sur les longs de pouvoir et sur les
imans 200 prix donc un volume énorme
c'est ça il ya ya un moment où c'est un
backup intérieur playmaker offensive il
ya un monde montre comme ça le dernier
que jamais de c'était une sorte noisy
champs de riz elle le ahly jefferson les
années 2020 quoi ouais donc il peut pas
gagner autant d'argent à quelques
personnes qui veut voir emballant mais
qui peut jouer peut-être entre 12 et 18
minutes dernier j'avais c'était orlando
robinson parce qu'il tient il tire
orlando fresno state
32% à 3 points sur deux tentatives par
match entre rennes si elle l'était à 35%
s'étaler sur trois tentatives 71 points
sur lancers francs donc à l'intérieur
siècle c'est sa carte d'entrée un
combined est qu'il avait une une semi
lueur de jours il n'hésitait pas à
lancer ce noir je pense que ce jour là
en tout cas au moins pour prouver des
choses et lui défensivement on n'est
plus sûr du droit bref appareils
utilisent la longueur sur du drop
bon eh ben on a on a cité beaucoup de
monde c'est une draft à grands
à partir du choix 20 il n'y a pas
beaucoup de bollwiller jeu parce qu'on
va se raconter avec manu mais
et et après des ailiers on peut toujours
en trouver mais surtout des grands donc
maintenant il faut il faut trouver la
valeur ajoutée dans le grand quoi mais
un grand toi tu vas pour finir là-dessus
on va peut-être plus facilement
drafté un grand vieux
parce que on se dit que c'est pas cher
en fait moi c'est un rôle qui peut être
plus facilement remplit rapidement c'est
là c'est un joueur qui peut être moins
cher c'est vrai que j'ai fait un article
et les intérieurs backup les meilleurs
et commence un peu à être bio payer
parce que c'est rare et que j'avais de
mcgill et à zahia hartenstein je pense
qu'il va prendre un peu d'argent aux
douanes damon pour la saison régulière
il faut en avoir daniel times ces
jours-là qui rendent série a au bout
d'un moment je pense qu'on se pose pas
fausses ou pour rendre service à un an
parce que dans des bus grandes joutes de
play-offs des grands matches un jour à
ce moule on jouera avec des intérieurs
qui va vous switchez oui a même un jour
tu sais veine krk talbot de grand
passage mais voilà juste que tu es mieux
c'est ça donc c'est puis sept puis je
pense est en possession de proue le
projette éthique peut être facilement
pris aussi parce que on va tous
spécialisés sur une ou deux choses donc
c'était des fois il sait c'est possible
au revoir aux joueurs qu'on pensait
d'eux plus fort offensivement que
défensivement et deux années dans
l'excès inverse parce qu'on est
spécialisé sur une ou deux choses je
pensais plus visible beaux poissons
intérieur quatre autres cadres de pouce
oui effectivement les les axes de
développement sur lesquels on va on va
insister à la fois sont peut-être moins
nombreux et aussi peut-être plus
facilement atteignable c'est à dire
qu'un un meneur de jeu tu veux le
développe études il faut développer son
dribble faut développer sa mobilité en
sortant des écrans pour qu'ils aient un
pool up à mi-distance et l'on s'est posé
à répétition balle en main vous n'avez
pas vraiment c'est le meilleur joueur
qu'ils ont la balle
parce que pour eux c'est plus posé de
très bons écrans la pression collective
sur demi terrain
et puis alors qu'il est le meilleur
poseurs d'écran du loing
pose plus d'excellence écran les joueurs
mais
j'ai peut-être tu déjà c'est-à-dire el
fadjr points tchité c'est un trop trop
moi j'avais très bien nous williams cela
fait longtemps que j'ai pas de diop mais
la 9e s'est quant à lui arrive à pleine
vitesse et que son défenseur a voulu
suivre - et que le rand d'entrée
viennent mondial
s'il bouge pas
effectivement et
le meilleur shooteur à terme
or john butler
je pense ce sera jeff lynne owens
ok je pense à ce rallye je vois vraiment
les pick'n papam ce possible très bien
et ben parce et on va clore cet épisode
donc spécialité intérieur ou en tout cas
pas shooter que shooter
protecteur de cercle et donc on se
retrouve pour les deux autres épisodes
avec les bolzan leurs alliés wings
espèrent vous avez apprécié c'était pour
vous faire connaître aussi des profils
qui risquent de tomber voit la fin de
premier tour au second tour ou même une
race red free agent et sur lesquels vous
pourriez vous poser des questions
n'hésitez pas à les consulter le site
abonnez vous sur votre plateforme des
coudes sur sur youtube si vous êtes en
train de regarder la vidéo en tout cas
de l'écouter sur youtube et puis aller
consulter tous nos tous nos autres nos
autres contenus elle annoncera tu seras
sur le plateau de la first team pour le
soir de la draft
on y sera romain sera sur bin et puis on
a plein de plein d'autres choses d'ici
là à vous faire découvrir à + alan en
plus à l'est ciao tout le monde by salut